maybe 20 people so it was wild to just
see how this whole industry has grown
it is amazing i've been doing a lot of
more meetings in person however in the
northeast i was in new york this week
they have had a spike of
covet outbreaks but primarily to people
that are vaccinated so the outcome is
nowhere near as bad as it was two years
ago but it looks like we're going to be
getting vaccinated every six months with
this thing yeah it's almost like a flu
shot and um
i think it's gonna it's here for it's
here to stay is another you know
pneumonia flu covet yeah
we're all going to be around
we'll have to learn to adjust
okay i think we are ready to get started
so thank you for everyone who's joining
us today and thank you kevin for being
here we are live streaming today's show
across zoom linkedin and youtube so
wherever you are watching this we are
very excited to have you uh before we
begin a couple quick things to note so
you can ask any questions and comments
in the chat members of the start engine
team are going to be answering those
throughout the event this is also a
pretty interactive show so feel free to
introduce yourself to your fellow
entrepreneurs and investors say where
you're from what you do and then just
share any reactions as these pitches are
actually happening and if you're
watching this event and you want to know
how you can invest in startups or in
alternative assets you can go to
starting.com we have over 200 companies
right now that you can invest in for as
little as 100
and of course you can follow start
engines instagram and social uh start
engine la we have a ton of startup
investing news we have sort of kevin's
tips for how to build your own portfolio
of investments and then we're going to
have live reactions to the pitches as
they're happening today
and for any first time viewers i am
joking cronin i'm the chief marketing
officer here at start engine we are the
leading equity crowdfunding site in the
us we've had over half a billion dollars
invested into startups and alternative
assets and of course i have with me our
judge and start engine strategic advisor
and investor kevin o'leary
great to be here and looking forward to
these pitches each one gets better
every time we do one of these it gets
more interesting so you're doing a great
job curating these contestants but also
we're seeing some amazing businesses
yeah the incredible thing is we get
thousands of applicants i know everyone
watching is only seeing these five
companies pitch but it is hours of going
through all of these applicants amazing
entrepreneurs and for so many of the
other entrepreneurs many of them are
planning on launching on start engine
they are still looking for ways to grow
their business and to find access to
capital so again we've we've whittled
this down to the top five but we have a
huge number of companies that have
applied to this
and then i just wanted to mention you
know we've been hosting these together
since 2020 and i think when we first
started most people had never heard of
equity crowdfunding i think definitely
most people had not invested in any
pre-ipo startups and now with over half
a billion dollars invested it feels like
that's really changing kevin do you have
any advice for anyone who's interested
in investing in startups but really
hasn't done it before
well the real game changer that's
occurred recently is allowing the
maximum you can raise to go from a
million seventy thousand dollars to five
million
which makes equity crowdfunding
incredibly competitive against
traditional venture capital hedge funds
private equity
now the other thing to know that is so
important about the attributes of equity
crowdfunding in start engine is you can
you create a democracy of shareholders
in other words if you look at
traditional term sheets from venture
capitalists they always have an element
of a preference to it
so they want their investment to have a
preference over everybody else in other
words when they exit what returns they
get the terms they get versus anybody
else that's a shareholder
i personally find that very distasteful
and i don't like it i've lived with it
for decades because there was no equity
crowdfunding but certainly now you don't
have to do that anymore because the
other thing to remember about equity
crowdfunding is it doesn't have any time
fuse on it if your customers become your
shareholders they may be in it for a
very long period of time which is a good
thing
versus you know a private equity fund or
a venture fund which has of a five to
seven year time horizon and as soon as
they get close to that after three years
they get very itchy to exit
and so you have to think about that as
well you want different classes of
shareholders that have different time
agendas i don't i'd rather just have a
democracy that is provided by the
platform of start engine and equity
crowdfunding i'm a huge advocate for
this
yeah i think that's amazing and we've
seen so many companies even companies
that had been considering other forms of
capital now turning to equity
crowdfunding for that exact reason they
want control of their business they want
to have instead of the typical strategic
investor they want to have that either
customers their fans their brand
ambassadors i mean there's not much
that's more strategic than that
absolutely
and then what about for investors so we
have a ton of investors a lot of them
come in because they hear about one
individual company or startup how would
you recommend building a portfolio i
mean we've talked a lot about not just
making a single investment but really
building out your portfolio of
investments
yeah i mean the thing about startups and
venture investing it definitely has
merits because the outcomes when you get
a winner are extraordinary thousands of
percent returns
but the key is what you think is going
to work sometimes doesn't and you need a
broad portfolio of companies so if
there's an area of interest you like
you're going to find it on start engine
with as many different offerings at any
one time but i recommend people have a
minimum of seven to ten separate venture
investments in their portfolio treat it
like an alternative asset class where it
definitely belongs in a portfolio and
say okay i don't you know if you think
about sheer diversification portfolio
analysis it generally looks like this
no more than 20 any one sector of the
economy there's 11 sectors in the s p
500 and no more than five percent
in any one stock that protects you
during times of extreme volatility so
you don't bet on one big outcome same
thing with start engine you want to be
in at least seven deals if not 10 or
even 15. so you build your portfolio
over time maybe you put 200 or a
thousand or 2000 each deal and then you
watch what happens you can stay in touch
with the companies as they communicate
with you as a shareholder which is great
but you want diversification so you know
you may hear something great today in
one of these companies or you may go to
the start engine.com platform of which
i'm a shareholder and a paid
spokesperson for obvious reasons i'm an
advocate but you definitely want to
browse and buy multiple opportunities
not just one
yeah i think that's really important
information as you're starting to build
out your portfolio and as kevin
mentioned you can have direct
communication with these founders so you
can actually ask them questions right on
the page it's all public ask about their
valuation their financials all of that
before making a decision of whether or
not to invest
so okay i think we we are ready to kick
it off we have some amazing companies we
have five entrepreneurs that are going
to be pitching today here's how it works
so we have the five pitches there's
going to be two minutes per pitch three
minutes for questions afterwards from
kevin and once all the pitches are
complete kevin is going to be choosing
the first place winner who will receive
the 25 000 cash prize a one-on-one with
start engine ceo and co-founder of
activision games howard marks and some
amazing prizes for our partners plug and
play deal brex and benzinga some of you
may have actually attended benzinga's
live stream this morning all of those
are incredible partners of ours and then
the second place prize is going to go to
the crowd favorite so everyone watching
will actually have the chance to vote
and select their favorite this company
will receive five thousand dollars from
the crowd
okay let's get started with our first
company ball street trading scott please
unmute your mic and turn on your camera
scott san emitario is the founder and
ceo of ball street trading he is
determined to provide fans a better way
to engage with live sports and esports
by using his 20 years of experience on
wall street please welcome scott
kevin it's great to meet you thank you
for the opportunity
i know you think day trading is gambling
so i think we have something for you
[Music]
to pitch the next draftkings
uh we want to approach a solution that
gamifies marketing and rewards fans for
their engagement and their time
in
2021 companies spend 180 million dollars
in digital ads and almost half of banner
ads remember actually being seen in our
vertical promotional dollars are the
headlines cpas across gaming operators
broker dealers and crypto exchanges are
as high as 2 000 per user how do you
solve this massive marketing problem we
created a free second screen platform
that pays fans for their attention and
loyalty via sponsorship dollars and
creates first party data as the nielsen
2.0 solution i know you're a big robin
hood guy and during the lockdown we all
got to see the sports bettors and retail
traders were the same person ball street
is a real-time play to earn prediction
mark that allows fans to compete against
each other during any live event from
the nfl and masters to esports and
midterm elections we see 71 minutes of
app open time per four hours of an event
with unit with users leaning in and
making almost 90 trades per contest we
have 50 000 accounts and achieved a 2.50
cpa through organic reach and key
partnerships event activation revenue
kicked off in q1 and we are working on
several high-profile long-term
partnerships to take the app global our
audience is exactly what advertisers are
looking for with 70 trading stocks
betting on sports and trading crypto
we have a multiple year
deal with riot games the nfl esports and
hosted our super bowl event with
benzinga with an average of 81 minutes
of active engagement during the game
itself
we are one of only a few approved
fantasy advisor partners for activision
esc entertainment and nvc we also have
high profile
financial influence on our cap table
this uniquely positions ball street for
distribution and scale offering a white
label experience enables us to be paid
to aggressively grow our mau's and
collect audience data this database is
key to launching a b2c revenue stream
with real money gaming opportunities our
team is anchored by senior
developers
as well as an advisory board that
includes the former cio of td ameritrade
as well as one of the former heads of
legal at penn national gaming as we look
forward we want to be able to raise and
close out our seed round of two million
dollars with the remaining 1.3
and think about revenue as a way to grow
fantasy as a service and compound over
time with bigger activations and real
money gaming revenue ball street is a
gaming and marketing affiliate model
that is looking to build the bridge
between gaming operators broker dealers
and crypto exchanges for the wall street
pets generation
okay
did you say that your customer
acquisition cost was two dollars and
fifty cents that's right we are a free
to play
platform so our organic reach has
allowed us to achieve those types of
metrics as well as our key partnerships
where the distribution of our partners
allows us to ultimately pull in their
customers as part of the campaigns that
we run to activate across their
broadcasts
so that is the key to this business is
acquiring customers what strategies are
you using how are you getting that so
low because that is a tenth of what it's
costing any gaming platform or any
betting platform or any sports betting
platform or any crypto trading platform
they're paying up to 200 per customer so
how are you doing that at 250 exactly
our ability to have these key
partnerships allows us to be a marketing
company and not a fantasy company to
start so what we've done is build a
trojan horse that allows us to attract
the reach and influence of our partners
as we overlay our markets live to their
broadcast so we have a partnership with
riot games where we host live markets
for their events on twitch so when those
events are going live we are integrated
into that broadcast those players or
those people who are watching those live
events ultimately come on to our
platform we are not paying a cpa on that
user they're coming in free we're
offering a prize or through a
sponsorship or through our ability with
riot to then offer them something that's
unique to that experience
now i saw your forecast on revenue but
you have any idea what the lifetime
value of a customer is going to be
what's your forecast
right now historically we see users play
almost seven contests now that gets
broken up into each individual product
right if you're an nfl fan doesn't mean
you're an nba fan doesn't mean you're a
major league baseball fan but on average
they play around seven times so for able
to churn through those users across
different types of products with
different types of sponsorships we
should be making several hundred dollars
on each of those users based on an event
calendar where we tackle the major tent
polls in conventional sports and
certainly being able to work through the
major publishers that we have
partnerships with
do you have any idea what your attrition
is in other words i download the app i
start using it how many are still on
there 30 60 90 days afterwards it's
dependent on the product but as an
example with the ncaa tournament we had
20 percent of our players trading every
single one of our march madness games we
saw almost 70 percent of players come
back for more than five of those
tournament days
okay so
ultimately
how do you think i should value this
business on the lifetime value of each
customer
is that where you think you're going to
get to
and how many customers do you think you
can have in the next two years
with the partnerships that we have
aligned we're looking to push north of a
million users from a global footprint
across esports and conventional sports i
think our evaluation comes from our
ability to attract those users and
ultimately bring them in to monetize
them from a marketing perspective
meaning we get to be able to sponsor out
our contests as well as ultimately
evolving those users into a real money
disney a real money gaming fantasy
operator perspective where those numbers
obviously begin to shift where we're
able to offer the opportunity of an ltv
obviously much higher which is where you
get some of these hundred dollar cpas
that these gaming operators are paying
lastly what geography is you operating
in state site only
right now it's global i mean we have the
app via url as well as in both app
stores and we are focused primarily in
north america but we certainly have
around 20 of our database that comes
from outside of the us that's mostly in
canada but certainly parts of europe and
mexico
but these park these partnerships are
primarily us right
the partnerships with esports it's kind
of a blended map it's not so easy for
you to say we're in north american
focused tournament operator everyone
that has access to twitch can ultimately
see where they want to watch these
events so for us our focus is when we
think about conventional sports
obviously we think about it regionally
focusing on north america but our
ability to have esports as a major
piece of this allows us to expand that
anything with f1 yet
uh we have spoken to mclaren a couple of
times but nothing specific with f1 that
is on the books it seems to be the
hottest thing right now and there's
nothing more we'd love to have markets
running for these f1 races that are
coming to the us yeah it's really hot
right now i'm seeing a lot of proposals
around f1 but listen fascinating great
job scott you definitely uh
nailed all the major points it's a very
interesting platform thank you
appreciate it thank you
great thank you so much scott okay next
up we have christina with kismet
technologies chris christina please
unmute your mic and turn on your camera
christina drake is the founder and ceo
of kismet technologies she was named to
the 2021 forbes next 1000 list and is
one of south florida business journals
healthcare innovators of 2020. her love
of star trek and material sciences
drives her to innovate technologies to
better human life please welcome
christina
hi everyone and hi kevin i'm very
excited to meet you today and i'm really
excited oops we lost that
let's get this back
i'm really excited to tell you today
about our award-winning and innovative
product that we call nanorad it offers
non-stop virus and bacteria protection
i'm christina drake i'm the ceo and
founder of kismet technologies and
kismet technologies is a pre-revenue
seed staged company that will be using a
b2b model for nina rad
our award-winning team has expertise
across business healthcare microbiology
and nanotechnology
so preventable infections are on the
rise even in the u.s where we buy and
use more disinfectant than any country
in the world and this causes problems in
places like hospitals and in closed
quarters such as on cruise ships
hospital acquired infections will cost
hospitals in the us 40 billion dollars a
year and norovirus infections which are
the typical outbreaks that you will see
on a cruise ship have economic losses of
11 billion dollars a year in the us
so this is why we developed nanorad it's
an unique coating that kills severe
germs not just
minor germs that cause scents but things
that cause severe illness like mrsa c
diff and norovirus it disinfects for
months even with cleaning of the surface
and it safely disinfects so you don't
have to worry about what happens when
you come into contact with it
nanowran reduces liability and illness
for critical organizations like
hospitals and in places that have severe
infection control needs such as cruise
ships
nanoranda is a very unique
residual antimicrobial that offers
features that
are needed in order to really tackle
infection problems
it offers continuous around-the-clock
protection it has a fast dry
disinfection time against viruses and
bacteria it safely disinfects when
people are present even when they're
interacting with the surface it works on
multiple types of surfaces and it's
effective against those really nasty
germs like mrsa and norovirus
today we have raised 350 k in safes and
256k and non-dilutive grants we're
currently working on pilots with
end-users to validate our market entry
points
we have one in progress with a
healthcare facility and we're working
with several hospital systems to get
pilots started there as well
we're also working with our b2b
customers and so we are focusing on
companies that already have sales
pathways into hospitals
and our
other potential market entry points such
as increased lines
and so why now
well current solutions aren't quite
cutting it that's why even in the us
where we use a lot of disinfectant we
still have infection issues and so
nanorad reimagines what disinfection can
look like where people get sick less
often when they encounter surfaces with
less waste to the planet and fewer
chemicals to people and the environment
in order to achieve disinfection
and so we hope you and anyone in the
audience that's listening will join us
on our mission to prevent infections
thank you
thank you christina um
the obvious question here is a little
bit more about go to market because
this at the end of the day sounds like
if it works the way you're suggesting
and it sounds very promising a consumer
goods product
that's the biggest market for it with
everybody after coming out of the
pandemic so concerned about
cleanliness and microbes and all of that
but that market is dominated by
behemoths so is the strategy to license
this technology or you're going to try
and get market share yourself in the
consumer cleanings good market yeah so
we will license with companies that
already sell in those markets and so we
have four companies that we are
currently working with um to basically
validate um our product and then we're
doing pilots with hospitals and [ __ ]
we'll be sharing those results with
those companies that we are working with
i like the hospital aspect why wouldn't
i want this in my home
and which which which companies are you
talking to that are actually direct to
consumer direct to home because this is
actually a giant retail market i mean
you look at cleaning fluids 90 of them
are sold on the shelf in grocery stores
etc
yeah so it's interesting because um in
the home
there are different infection control
issues than um in places where you have
a lot of people
um and in terms of liability um in terms
of pain point where people are willing
to really pay more um for specialized
you know disinfecting coding effectively
um it seemed from our customer
interviews that really hospitals were
the ones that were now they want to pay
for that product now um and so we've
focused so what what premium is the cost
versus if i just spray you know or use
clorox or something else or lysol how
much more expensive is this
so the upfront cost of the purchase um
is about five times more expensive but
over the life of the product let's say
over a year you're only reapplying four
times so it ends up over the lifetime of
or not lifetime but over the period of
one year it ends up being a third of the
price of what you would spend to then
buy and put disinfectant out on every
surface so the yeah so so the outs
to suppressing uh
transmission in a hospital is a
measurable cost i assume so at the end
of the day these tests are going to
prove that it reduces infection
therefore reducing cost reducing
liability reducing insurance is that
sort of what you're doing
yes and it's that um reimbursement from
insurance so when a hospital has an
infection um they are not reimbursed for
that patient um who got sick in their
facility
okay and so revenue
yeah revenue model two years out from
now what do you hope to be generating in
revenue
so we hope to have um five to six
full-size hospitals and we are looking
at four to six million
in 24 months okay fascinating thank you
very much
thank you
ray thank you so much christina okay
next we have current foods jasic please
unmute your mic and turn on your camera
jasek prus is the founder of current
foods he's on a mission to reimagine the
future of food in order to sustainably
and satisfyingly feed the world's next
billion people after two years of r d he
has created seafood from plants that
goes toe-to-toe with with the
traditional stuff from taste texture and
nutritional density please welcome jasic
hey mr o'leary uh thank you and start
engine for this opportunity i'm jc percy
co-founder and ceo of current foods
um we're creating the next generation of
seafood that happens to be made from
plants
the reason we're doing this is because
there are not enough fish in the sea uh
since 1970 50 percent of ocean fish have
been pulled out of the water 70 percent
of sharks and 97 of bluefin tuna
environmental emission problems are
actually quite rampant and bottom
trawling alone creates more greenhouse
gas emissions than the entire aviation
industry and there's also a ton of
health concerns um there's more uh
pieces of microplastic than there are
stars in the galaxy so they're starting
to peripherally through the ocean
ecosystem um
mercury parasites food poisoning these
are all problems in seafood um but this
is also a massive opportunity a 455
billion dollar opportunity
um and it's a market that's growing so
seafood protein demand is
actually escalating more and more
um so
it's a it's a pretty big thing to go
after and you know we don't want to boil
the whole whole ocean we're really
focusing on high-end markets for these
products like raw seafood and smoked
salmon
so you can see here our first two
products uh current tuna and currant
smoked salmon they're made from peas
bamboo algae potato essentially they're
clean label
our protein our products have protein
omega-3 dha iron and a lot of other
health benefits
and what's great about our products is
they have price parity to the animal
counterpart
and that's notoriously difficult in the
food space
so beyond being nutritious healthy
affordable most importantly
they're delicious
and they're delicious because of our
technology of texturization so
um
the backbone of our products is created
through this texture
through really really optimized
ingredients this is where we can get p
protein to be highly soluble
and this is through hydrolyzation other
enzymatic treatments but also complex
processes such as layering
and you know some of our depositing
processes so
it's really great is these complex
processes which have you know
intellectual property are also
like able to be done on a massive scale
um this is really important for us
because to achieve our goal to save the
oceans we really have to um you know
replace a lot of fish and so our new
facility will create 200 000 pounds of
product a month essentially 1.6 million
dollars worth of revenue each month
um and that's just our first facility
this is really possible because of our
incredible team so
you know in my background i was an
animal rights activist in the past got
an mba in entrepreneurship helped to
find an accelerator and then founded
current foods my co-founder is an
incredible food scientist
and we just have a whole slew of people
who have scaled fitbit jewel production
systems um and just an incredible team
so we're pre-revenue company we've been
testing with select partners across the
united states and europe and in the next
24 months we will launch into mass
market we expect a total of seven
million dollars in revenue by then so
we're just closing our seed round and
really bringing in partners who funded
and built beyond me sat on their board
they pushed their ipo
got a great playbook to scale um to take
this company to promise land but we're
always looking for people who understand
and can help us get our product to the
market thanks for your time
so let's talk about the stability of the
product is it does it require
refrigeration is it frozen
how is it delivered to the end user or
to the grocer if it's sold there
yes it is frozen and
chilled on site by the by the user
so
you require a freezer space in your
rollout strategy to grocers right
yes
okay so excuse me i'm just going to turn
off my cell phone here
sorry for the interruption
so
bottom line um
the mission on plant-based is right on
for market i get it i mean we see a lot
of these on shark tank and there's a
quite a bit of demand can i say this
also fits in a vegan mandate does it fit
in a keto mandate what what other sub
segments does it also support
yeah vegan is definitely a big market um
you know
pregnant women so this is actually
really interesting but pregnant women
children um especially with raw tuna and
the mercury problems there um
essentially we're targeting the
flexitarian consumer and we believe the
flexitarian will eat our products as
long as they taste great they're
affordable and they can be found easily
and you're saying it has price parity
with smoked salmon and with with tuna
yeah and it's only going to get better
we're at pilot scale so we'll eventually
undercut all those costs
okay so really what you need is trial
you need adoption through trial if you
your claims of it tasting that great
this is a product i would try i mean i'm
very concerned about
uh mercury and fish i eat a lot of fish
that so and so it's always on my mind
how much salt is in it to give it the
flavor
if i looked at i want to compare the
protein i get and the salt component in
a traditional smoked salmon yes there's
saline in there and what does yours look
like
our smoke our salt levels are actually
significantly lower than smoked salmon
um
so we have actually a really big benefit
there
and this doesn't mention all the
antibiotics issues or the micro plastics
for the mercury
we can and and our our ingredients would
just get further and further optimized
so we've done all of this so far off of
uh six million uh dollars which sounds
like a lot but when you're creating
really good food products you know you
need quite a bit of capital so it's just
the beginning right now what's the path
of the next product
um we're going to well we're going to
take those two products and we really
want to scale them and push them
i think it's a six billion market in the
united states
um
and
you know we're talking about tens of
millions in revenue there if we um just
take one percent but if we start to get
to 15 we're getting the hundreds of
millions um and beyond me was you know
just getting a 100 million one at ipo so
other than that i mean there's cooked
products as well so pouch tuna
cooked salmon um plenty of things and
you know we also have people in japan
right now who are begging us to order
some pallets over there so
the world's awesome i'm just wondering
on them from a marketing basis getting
to market because you're pre-revenue how
do you get people to try this what is
the plan for trial because it's a frozen
product getting into the frozen section
of a grocer
as i've learned over the last 10 years
because i've had many food products is
very very challenging particularly you
know
because it's it's all it's already
filled you have to knock something out
to put your product there now that's the
negative the positive is plant-based
products are growing wildly we both know
that and that's important and it really
boils down to trial i i need to try it
to rebuy it and i just want to
understand what that strategy is yeah so
we've been launched with about 60
locations some of them for about nine
months um and we've been repurchasing
with they've been repeat purchasing from
us which is to us the biggest signifier
that we've created something that sticks
these are like high-end retailers who do
it in their food service element
high-end sushi bars um you know like
latin latin themed places where we have
it in ceviche high-end sushi bars are
reordering
yes
so
so okay that that means it doesn't taste
like [ __ ] that's interesting
it tastes good it tastes good kevin and
we'll be more than happy to get you guys
some product um if you're in miami i'm
actually uh in florida in about a few
days so no i definitely want to try
i definitely want to try this i i'm this
is a this is right on mandate for where
there's growth in the food category
fascinating story thank you very much
thanks for your time yeah
great thank you so much jasic
that was quite the pitch sounds like
you're going to have uh
some alternative meets set your way very
soon
well if he if it really is as he says
he's got something big here
yeah i i totally agree
okay so just a quick reset for anyone
who is joining us right now this is
start engines shark pitch with mr
wonderful and i'm seeing a ton of people
in the chat asking how can i pitch at
the next show if you go to start
engine.com shark you can apply to pitch
again we get thousands of applicants
we're only able to choose five companies
but we also speak to all of those
companies about possibly raising their
next round of funding on start engine so
again if you are interested in pitching
or interested in raising go to start
engine.com
shark
and so kevin okay we're three pitches in
we have two left we're going to i think
we're going to have a you know our work
cut out for us in terms of choosing who
this winner is going to be yeah it's
just you know
the problem is each each session each
time we do one of these the the
companies get better and better and
better in just terms of what they're
bringing forward and that's probably as
people are starting to you know
understand with start engineers i kind
of get it um but this is going to be
just between these three so far
this is already a problem these are all
great ideas all of them all of them
there's no dog here yet so i don't want
to say i hope i get a dog in the next
one but but so far
um wow so these are all i mean if you
think about a portfolio you'd want to
own a piece of all of these they're all
in different sectors they all have
really good ideas and they are they're
solved they're solving big problems and
so that's generally what makes for a
good startup
yeah and i think this gives you a good
indication of what you'd see on start
engine so you see you know you might
have green tech you might have a brick
and mortar store it it's such a wide
variety of the types of companies that
you can invest in and that's why when we
put together this pitch competition we
really want to have a wide selection so
okay i know we're close on time so
without further ado let's go to our
pitch number four
zolt ani please unmute your mic and turn
on your camera ani column is the
co-founder and chief marketing officer
of zolt a plant-based wellness brand in
the functional beverage space ani has 20
years of experience working with
consumer facing startups and retail
brands from tommy tommy hilfiger and
macy's she received her mba from boston
university please welcome omni
thank you so much joanna and so great to
meet you kevin
i'm just sharing my screen
[Music]
great
so
the only way to keep your health is to
eat what you want you don't want drink
what you don't like and do what you
would rather not
we love mark twain but thanks to zolt
this quote has really aged poorly
that's because we're on a mission to
make everyday wellness simple and
delicious optimizing functional plants
and fungi and transforming them into
great testing tasting convenient drink
mixes that allow you to tap into their
therapeutic benefits across four areas
of health
focus balance immunity and sleep
zolt even helps make it easier to get
through your day better
being sharp in that 8 a.m zoom meeting
or falling asleep soundly at night
in a nutshell zolt helps people live
their days more fully and more
effectively
we develop our super powders using
organic adaptogens antioxidants and a
novel approach to drying terpenes which
are highly volatile aromatic compounds
most commonly known in cannabis and wine
and we work with them to dissolve them
easily into a reusable water bottle and
taste super delicious which by the way
is no small feat giving the earthing
given the earthiness of many of our
ingredients
we know our timing's right as you
mentioned kevin um consumers are turning
to new wellness solutions to mitigate
daily stressors leveraging functional
plant-based foods to do so
in addition terpenes an area that we're
super passionate about
is indicated as the next big thing by
nutraceutical world
we've mapped several strains of cannabis
and replicated their therapeutic effects
using citrus and other plant compounds
to impact mood mind and body
we sit at the intersection of functional
beverage plant-based foods and
nutraceutical supplements which we
estimate to be at about 18 billion in
tam
we've definitely got a competitive edge
we have strong margins and strategic
partnerships in place our pioneering
terpene innovation which is largely
untapped in our market
is is thriving we have new product
category potential and a six-month
product launch timeline
our small and mighty team is comprised
of seasoned players in the consumer
space across strategy design and content
my co-founder doug has spent his career
in beverage as a former ceo of a wine
and spirits distributor he's also a
total health nut and our consumer zero
for every product that we develop or
decide not to
we're future ready with a robust product
pipeline and as you can see here even as
a young company we've gotten some really
great press so far
in addition we sit with many formidable
players on retail shelves like vital
protein and ollie
we did 500 000 in our first full year um
we launched in bed bath and beyond 15
months in
we've been accepted to amazon's launch
pad program are partnered with unfi
and are launching in kroger and vitacost
online later this month
our near-term pipeline includes a
national wellness retailer specialty
stores and an international partner with
1500 doors
in terms of our online performance our
conversion rate's 2.2 percent um which
in e-commerce is pretty strong our aov
60 and our cac is 48 for nudibrand
we're projecting modest growth in 22
with a robust expansion in 23.
we're currently seed around fundraising
two and a half million and are
about 20 percent there um these funds
are going to be spread across product
development inventory marketing and
sales and then adding head count
so thank you so much for having us today
here um we're super excited to be able
to truly systematize super plants and
beverage and we can't wait to continue
to scale
okay so definitely on trend for consumer
preferences but i want to get into the
metrics giving you have sales what what
percentage is direct consumer what
percentage of sales is going through
retail
um so d to c 21 was about 25
and the rest was going through retail
um and then we're projecting similar
breakdown for 2022.
2023 is where we're gonna really see
that growth in wholesale um ramp up and
that's obviously going to feed into our
d2c
so
21 direct consumer on the metrics what's
your customer acquisition cost and what
do you know now about life lifetime
value in other words you have enough
data to tell me
is is the attrition high do people try
it and then drop it or do they stick
with it and reorder it
um so our cat currently is 48 at dollars
that's a little bit lower than it had
been previously just because we're
diversifying off of facebook and
instagram just because it's so expensive
with all of the ios changes
um
in terms of lifetime value i mean we're
still super young um but we are looking
at somewhere around like
three to four hundred dollars
um so definitely that's over a four year
period our ltv to cac would hopefully be
somewhere around three to four
and do you know what your attrition rate
is how many people that try it reorder
it um so we have about a 25 repeat rate
currently i'd like that to definitely be
higher um we just rolled out a
subscription program recently which i
think is going to absolutely help um and
also launching a referral program
what is the let's go to the product
itself now how many cat how many
calories how many sugars how much salt
what's the breakout um so it breaks down
uh it's different per product but
we have certain products that have zero
grams of sugar
um some have one organic cane sugar and
stevia is a blend um and our highest is
four grams um calories don't go above 15
per six pack
okay
cost what does it cost for a typical
serving um cost for us
yeah no cost for you and cost to the
customer sure so um our margin is around
68 the cost of the customer for one
serving um is depending on the product
anywhere from 250 to three dollars
that absolutely is on our radar to bring
down as we get additional scale
particularly if we're able to launch in
say a target where price point is going
to be important and when i see it in
retail am i getting multiple packets and
what does that cost um so we sell them
in packs of 10 for the most part um so
at bed bath and beyond you can get um
one for focus immunity wellness uh
and sleep and then we also have a
variety pack
okay
last question
when you sell to retail do you capture
customer information
um
it's challenging right now um we are
seeing people come back to the brand um
and so we're getting that anecdotally we
absolutely do see lifts um when we get
press we'll see that left at retail and
then come back at direct to consumer but
we're not there yet to be able to get
that info and one last question on the
packaging is there appeal to go to the
website is there a way that you're
trying to convert them to become direct
to consumer um yep absolutely and and
then you also have a qr code where you
can scan and get info on all of the
ingredients as well
okay thank you very much
thank you
great thank you so much ani okay we have
our final presenter
greener process systems matt please
unmute your mic and turn on your camera
matt sweetwood is the ceo of greener
process systems and has a master's
degree in mathematics from university of
pennsylvania he grew his previous
company from one million dollars to 100
million dollars before a successful exit
greener process systems has developed a
patented air pollution capture system
for ocean-going ships in port please
welcome matt
hello kevin hello start engine audience
when i successfully exited my 100
million dollar company in 2015 i said i
would only take on a problem is if it
solved a significant one so let me tell
you about a worldwide air pollution
problem that affects both the
environment and the health of millions
of people
a study conducted by the epa shows that
70 percent of pollution in urban areas
near ports is caused exclusively by
stationing ships docked in ports
including many toxic and cancerous
pollutants on average one large
ocean-going ship emits the equivalent of
more than 20 000 cars
not equipped with catalytic converters
the epa estimates the cost to us alone
is in the hundreds of billions of
dollars
the health effects can include premature
mortality increased hospital admissions
increase cancer risk and increase
respiratory issues like asthma
and if you've ever lived or been close
to long beach california you know this
it's taken 15 years of development but
we've solved the problem with our
patented capture technology called seth
ship emissions treatment in harbor
seth attacks attaches to the smoke
stacks of ships
using advanced robotics and captures
emissions
we have three versions of seth
one on a hybrid barge
on a rail on the dock and one of the
first of its kind an all-electric barge
seth is 98 effective at capturing the
bad stuff in ship air pollution and the
system reduces carbon emissions too
the final process
filters ship exhaust into a small amount
of dry particles
our technology allows the continued use
of fossil fuels it saves freight
companies and cruise lines money seth
preserves and creates jobs and cleans
the environment at the same time
we are an experienced group of engineers
and entrepreneurs with many patents and
trademarks among us
enrico our founder and chief engineer
brings over 35 years of environmental
management experience he's led several
research projects with italian
universities maurizio our ceo brings
over 18 years of development experience
holds a bs in computer science and a
dual master's degree in engineering and
aeronautics from the university of
bologna in italy
the world market for seth is large
there's four thousand doctors contained
in about two thousand ports worldwide
and we're very excited to have received
the 10 million order to install all
three versions of our assess system in
europe next year
thank you kevin for listening and i'm
now ready to uh take your questions
so
my question is about
capital if i own a craft or i own a
fleet or if i own a cruise ship line
give me the economics for retrofitting
all of these
giant
assets and what's my return on
investment
okay so our system is designed and this
is part of the magic of what we do is
our system can fit essentially on any
kind of freighter or cruise ship there
nothing has to be done to those ships
and in fact uh you would say well okay
it's an environmental product it filters
there why would they care
when a ship is imported actually is
required to burn a much more expensive
fuel
um so with the set our assess system
operating ships and harbor can use
something called intermediate fuel oil
instead of maritime gas oil which
provides a savings of about four hundred
dollars per metric ton and that's about
a fuel cost savings about three hundred
dollars to sixteen hundred dollars per
ship so it's a big deal for
the the freight the freighters and the
cruise line it's a big deal for the
ports who are under increasing pressure
to reduce air pollution because this
problem is obviously a huge problem
worldwide and has exist
do i buy the product from you as a ship
owner what does it cost me um so the
this is going to be sold primarily to
the ports um a system depending on its
configuration because every port is
different a system can cost as little as
five hundred thousand dollars it can be
as much as four million
dollars once again does the port does
the port charge me as an operator
because somebody has to recoup that half
a million dollars exactly so we
anticipate we anticipate there'll be
several sources of revenue uh one the
port operators will charge the freight
chips because they do gain that fuel
savings in addition there's lots of
advertising uh opportunities billboard
space and so on on the actual operating
equipment which you know should provide
a continued source of revenue
so
can they mandate this will the ports buy
this and then force every ship to use it
are you at that place yet yeah because
the the governments are requiring the
ports to reduce their emissions there's
there's all sorts of deadlines where
they have to reduce by 20 by here
depending upon where you are if you take
for example in singapore they're
building a massive newport in singapore
one of the busiest freight hubs in the
world and they have mandates in place
that says by 2030 they have to reduce
the air pollution
so who's your who's your competition
where else can i get this service from
um there is no competition for what
we're doing there have been some
attempts to do this kind of thing but
nobody has succeeded um there's
something called cold ironing which
requires ships to actually plug into the
shore but freighters to retrofit that
but as the question you initially asked
in the beginning it's not really
feasible to do that the power grids in
the cities particularly if you think of
some of the cities in europe and someone
could not support that so there really
is no competition it's why it makes our
solution unique and why we've actually
won this contract to install them in uh
in europe
and can you verify that you're reducing
carbon emissions
yep we um we produced a prototype and
that's where our our data comes from uh
and we've our overall effect is about a
98 reduction and that's because of the
way our capture technology works and
actually seals over the smoke stack i
emphasize this is not an easy task
because you have various smoke stacks at
various heights various angles and so on
and you also have to make a seal which
requires you to monitor temperature and
flow so you don't cause problems on the
ship so that's part of the magic pilot
why it took so long
and do you have to provide some kind of
uh liability protection should you
damage the ship engine is that a concern
is there
is that part of the cost when a ship
says wait a second i've never tried this
before how do i know you're you're not
going to damage my multi-million dollar
diesel engine yeah absolutely so we're
actually in the process of acquiring
insurance uh and working with that right
now but
obviously um ships are going to be
forced to sign a waiver because this is
air pollution
and they're going to be required to
mitigate this so i'm not even sure that
this is going to be an issue going
forward they're just going to have
basically no choice but to do this and
where do you store the carbon you're
sequestering
um well the um the output of our system
is a dry output it's actually you have
to realize the particles are microscopic
so even a one large chip running for a
long time only produces a very small
amount of dry particles those particles
are non-hazardous they can simply be
carted away to a landfill we're also
discussing possible uses of those
materials once we have enough of these
systems installed they can go into roads
into green cities and so on into
plantings and so on so we're in
discussions to do that
okay last question
um
how many ports have you got under
contract right now right now there's
three ports and they're going to take
each version of our system one on a
hybrid barge which is an electric barge
with a
diesel backup one is on a rail on the
dock and one is actually on an
all-electric barge which we're very
proud of because we've done some of our
own engineering on that and it's going
to be one of the first of its kind which
is great for us because we'll be able to
demo all three versions that we have
okay one last question if every ship has
to have this if that's the mandate won't
you need multiple versions of that in
every port there's hundreds of ships
yeah that's really good news
and the answer is one unit if you think
of it it's on a barge it only takes in
the exhaust when the ship is in port
when the ship leaves fort another ship
can go in and use the same unit in a
place like long beach yes they will need
multiple units there's other ports that
only have several three four five ships
that come in at a time there's ferries
where you just need actually one unit
sitting there so it depends on the
configuration of course but it's good i
view that as a good thing we'll be able
to install more of them
thank you very much that's a fascinating
presentation thank you
thank you
great thank you so much matt okay and
thank you to everyone we had five
amazing pitches i already see inside of
the chat a ton of people sharing what
their
favorites are some that they thought did
a little work
but you guys are all going to get the
chance to vote so in the next minute or
so you will actually see
a crowd favorite poll pop up
everyone who's watching is going to get
the chance to choose who they think
should win the crowd favorite plot prize
which again is 5 000
kevin without revealing who you are
going to select walk me through what
you're considering for each one of these
so ball street was really fascinating
because you can understand how it
aggregates value uh to the customers i
mean that's
very interesting and and
what was fascinating about that deal was
the low customer acquisition costs
because it's it's you're all you're
almost provide you're burdening that
cost on the partner which
you know i was really impressed with
that christina and and nano um the cost
is going to make it an industrial
product i think in hospitals but it also
has a fascinating outcome in reducing
their liability and costs so i thought
that was a great product um
current foods i mean
it's all about how it tastes and so you
know it's such it but if i if if i'm to
believe um
what jessic said and that high-end sushi
restaurants are reordering it and
they're very concerned about the
experience because hayan sushi's really
expensive but
that's just a fascinating story i heard
nobu uh has actually used their products
yeah so i mean you know
that's just
that's really interesting and so on
mandate for people going on plant based
i mean it's it's you know something i'm
very involved in as well zolt um
great product clearly because they're
getting uh
you know they're getting distribution
but i would have liked to have seen more
direct consumer but they have it i mean
they've got 21 i wish it was 50. but
there is a way to get there when people
really get behind the product because
it's a reused product once you get into
your smoothie if you want to call it
that or whatever you want to call this
beverage
it's a it's a daily routine and so the
outcome is really good and you know
everybody has their their their smoothie
or their drink i'm included in that too
every day so to extend salt can get
those customers that's fantastic and
greener is just
it just really i mean you know these are
fantastic ideas it's it's um
it's going to be a tough one it's going
to be a tough one
it's truly we because my team basically
we go through all the thousands of
companies we speak to so many different
entrepreneurs and you can imagine the
amazing companies that just it you
whittle down to these top five so again
i know a lot of people are watching i
see the chats with tons of people saying
i want to pitch if you go to start
engine dot com shark you can apply to
pitch in the next round uh but
okay i think we have uh do you have a
winner are you already ready to uh
present before before you do that i want
to remind everyone what's at stake
um so the winner is going to get
25 000 in cash
one on one with start engine ceo howard
marks and amazing services from our
partners at plug and play brex deal and
benzinga so plug and play is going to be
offering their playbook they also have a
mentorship session with their venture
and investment partners in six months of
desk space at their headquarters in
sunnyvale brex is going to be offering a
50 000 point sign up bonus and priority
onboarding benzinga a company that
really you know has been a great partner
of ours they have a huge community of
investors and readers they will offer a
featured article written by a top
benzinga editor
and deal is going to have 50 off
contractors and 20 off employees with
the first employee free for 12 months
and on one on one business consultation
with deal's ceo
so that's what's at stake kevin are you
ready to announce the winner of this
shark pitch
yes i am um and again this is the
hardest of ever i mean they just get
harder and harder because the companies
are so good
um i have to give it to current foods um
because the size of the market is so
huge
and the company's at the cusp of
delivering scale the biggest questions
often raised on plant-based products is
how do you scale how do you make this
work if people actually engage and start
putting a part of their diet and we see
so many of these companies and and i've
seen but on this is so on mandate and so
current for what people are looking for
and it was a fantastic presentation
and um
i just say that even without tasting it
yeah because you know that he he got me
he got because i wasn't gonna go there
because most of these things taste like
[ __ ] i'm sorry to say that but the fact
that they had reordered in their pilots
from major sushi restaurants which i
know are incredibly sensitive to what
they put out on the plate because they
charge so much and their margins are so
so high and then you disclose nobu which
is about as high end as you can get
um
like wow yeah we actually have jasic do
you want to unmute yourself and and say
a couple words
yeah i mean this is awesome thanks for
uh thanks for the support and i'm
actually kind of surprised i mean i do
have a big ego but these are some really
good companies here so
um
i'm going to make sure you're going to
get some good sushi kevin
yeah you know i got to tell you jasik
you're getting this this prize package
uh is the biggest it's ever been there's
a lot of really good tools in here that
you should take advantage of as you i
mean the word's going to get out there
you should make sure that you have
product available for trial with all
this news coming
yeah you know people are very motivated
when they hear a new idea to try it
particularly on your claims of taste
if it's true and the texture is right
this is going to be a huge home run
thanks kevin i mean we're just getting
out to market on mass so this is going
to be um
perfect timing
yeah awesome thanks congratulations
and then for the crowd favorite so kevin
as you know the shark does not always
agree with the crowd and in this
situation
that was also the case so the winner
from the crowd is greener process
systems uh that is going to be a 5 000
prize in cash thank you so much if you
want to say a couple words matt thank
the crowd the crowd yeah of course
kevin thank you for giving me the
opportunity to convince the crowd that
we're the best so i appreciate that
and uh we're excited because we're gonna
go out there and and save the planet
yeah listen i thought your presentation
was spectacular and the opportunities i
love it when the market is a mandate in
other words if these ports basically
make it that way then um i think it's a
great you listen you were
just to be clear you're my second choice
that's why
that's what the women usually tell me
but what can i say
[Laughter]
anyways thank you again i appreciate it
thank you start engine very grateful for
the opportunity
it's terrific just terrific
thank you so much matt and a huge thank
you to all five companies who pitched
they really did an incredible job and
thank you to our sponsors plug and play
brex deal and benzinga and of course to
you kevin another great shark pitch in
the books
yes thank you it's great congratulations
everybody and
wow i mean it's it's getting harder and
harder i can't say that enough these are
all great companies good work in getting
us diversification joanna good morning
exactly and for anyone who wants to
invest in startups today and can't wait
for these companies just go to start
engine.com we have over 200 companies
just like this that you can invest in
for as little as a hundred dollars
okay that wraps up shark pitch and thank
you so much kevin
take care bye-bye see you next time bye